[Music]  hashtag christmas recycling  2020 with christmas upon us  it's time to enjoy family and food  and that one special toy  it's also a time when our waste is  increased  so let's think about what we do to  decrease  try paper not foil to wrap up those  gifts  [Music]  as this is recyclable a trick not to  miss  then there is food and leftovers from  dinner why not reuse  then everyone's a winner  cardboard and paper real trees and  turkey bones  we collect and recycle as you clear out  your homes  remember this year as you put out your  waste  that suez are out collecting with haste  to keep our streets tidy the best way  they can  so recycle reuse as much  as you can check out our website  for the festive collections  for tips and advice and lots of  suggestions  let us all work together and continue to  be  one of the best in the country at  recycling are we  christmas from rochford district council